the possession of Hannah grace is a
horror film that was released this
weekend no one's really talking about it
it came out at the end of November so
it's a movie and it's released it's from
Sony and Screen Gems so it's it's real
it's actually a movie that they put in
theaters and I had no idea what it was I
just saw it and said oh I'm gonna go see
it cuz it's a horror movie that got
released did anyone know this movie was
coming out so in the opening scene a
girl named Hannah grace is possessed and
she is killed while possessed due to a
failed exorcism and her body is brought
to the morgue where a recovering addict
is working the night shift for the first
time and since Hannah was killed during
this exorcism there's some stuff left
behind still that begins to mess with
our nice nightshift morgue worker this
movie you know it's a movie where a girl
crawls around and she goes it's one of
those movies so I mean it's you know
exactly what I mean just by saying that
I don't have to say anything else the
film is 85 minutes long with credits and
so the majority of the movie is this
girl Megan played by Shay Mitchell who
used to be a former cop wandering around
hallways doors open weird sounds occur
and maybe there's a dead body that might
be causing this that's almost the entire
film this is a very limited cast
obviously the idea was let's do an
exorcism movie but with a slight twist
to it and we'll have it all be in one
small spots in one contained moment of
time and it'll be cheap and it'll
probably make its budget back in the
opening weekend it'll be super easy
let's just make it we'll call it the
possession of Hannah grace despite the
fact that that sounds like a billion
other titles we've heard the Exorcism of
Emily Rose the haunting of Molly Hartley
even the plot is reminiscent of a film
called last shift that came out in 2014
which was about a cop at a police
station working the night shift and
there were some creepy goings-on
happening and that film was considerably
better than this movie this is one of
the mo
uneventful horror movies I remember
seeing in recent memory and that's not
to say this is a film without effort
they do try early on to give a backstory
to the lead character Megan they try to
have a bit of a twist to the exorcism
plot that we've seen a thousand times
and the director is trying to at least
craft some creepy sequences he doesn't
overly rely on musical score the sound
design actually does a lot of the work
here which I was impressed by you can
tell that he is trying it's just that
the script is literally just a series of
creepy scenes that really don't lead to
much when your entire movie is just
someone walking around and seeing creepy
stuff every once in a while coming out
of a shadow when you're waiting for
something anything to happen besides a
scene that ends with somebody saying oh
I gotcha you're waiting for something to
occur that justifies the movie's
existence everything about the film just
feels like a movie that was made to make
a return on their investment this is an
investment movie there's nothing to it
it's not the worst film ever made it's
certainly not one of the better exorcism
or possession movies in fact it's not
even about a possession so the title is
misleading the possession happens before
the movie even starts and it has nothing
to do really with a plot the film has a
couple glaring plot holes - one
involving the father of Hannah Grace who
early on proves that he will go to great
lengths to save his daughter but later
goes to even more extreme lengths and
we're supposed to somehow understand
what he's doing despite some really
horrible things he does and another once
we discover what Hannah grace is
actually trying to do and what she's
capable of doing she has the opportunity
to accomplish something that would
greatly benefit her but she doesn't she
just kind of gives someone a way out of
a scenario for some reason even though
everyone else met a considerably more
gruesome fate despite an attempt to
craft some scary sequences and an
attempt
to craft a somewhat compelling lead
character it's all thrown away to have a
girl creepily walking around contorting
her body you know it's taken about 200
of these movies for me to realize that
demons apparently don't really give a
shit about travel time because that's
got to be the slowest fucking way to get
anywhere if you're gonna possess a body
at least make it walk or run yeah I'm
gonna give the possession of Hannah
grace a d-plus
there really isn't that much more to say
they try early on a little bit there's
little Easter eggs hidden throughout if
you're paying attention like a the
lights above her flickering on and off
creating the upside-down cross which
again is something that's been in a lot
of these movies they try a little bit
and then they just give up and make a
movie where somebody walks around in a
hallway whatever that's my review of
this film I wouldn't really recommend it
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I look forward to more reviews
very soon and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]